hello there the internet aren't gap
under usually we get a lot of
suggestions from you the audience
and we appreciate them and we often
shoot them and we've done quite a lot
nobody suggested this one its gargling I
wrote this down about five years ago
because I thought it might look
interesting and I see I have no idea if
we look interesting but I really wanna
see if we can see some like rippling in
your uvula
everything is always soft stuff in there
isn't it so everything it should be
quite good actually I'll either be
really boring or fascinatingly gross
that's why no taken advantage of that
winter Sun getting dangling into my god
think about this the light travelled for
eight minutes across space went into
your mouth and hit your uvula bounce
back it's the lens in two LEDs went onto
the internet millions of people saw it
really fine fine okay
it's like Oh
yeah yeah oh it's like a shark attacking
a bunch of why did this they mesmerize
that was brewed grief yeah why we love
wearing lab coats for that I mean what
cuz I we didn't really learn everything
all I did was gargle and I was wearing a
lab coat I'm sure someone could figure
out the frequency of your uvula when it
was thrashing around like a shark we've
benefited society in this there we go
yeah well hopefully you've recovered
from that we we've almost recovered just
remember every time you brush your teeth
in gargle that is happening in your
mouth okay so think about that next time
you doing it
I don't want no no I want to think about
it screaming and you don't have a very
big uvula I've seen mines bigger we
should do uvula auditions he's got a big
you've you've got a massive I once heard
that uvula was Latin a little great
that's a great I think I wouldn't to eat
it
people like uvulas alright well feel
free to follow us on Twitter subscribe
to this channel if you love them oh and
uh you could buy a shirt and a poster
also excuse see the next video let's do
this let's do did you know I'm in a
movie
well I am and it's called lazer team and
there are still tickets available to the
very first screenings on the 27th and
the 28th of January in the US Canada UK
Australia even New Zealand as well far
away so if you fancy seeing a movie what
I am in click the link and get yourself
a ticket